hey guys it's Justine and welcome back
to my kitchen I know a lot of you guys
have missed my baking videos so today I
thought that I would try to recreate an
old classic I once tried to make a
pumpkin pie and so many things went
wrong that I watched this video I
studied it and I figured out all the
things that I did wrong I made myself a
mental list and now we're gonna remake
this pumpkin pie today I'm using the
amazon firetv cube in my kitchen so
right now I can see the television right
here so I can have side by side what I'm
doing and re watching the old video that
I made before so I won't make the same
mistakes first things first
Alexa turn on my TV this is great
hands-free I basically have Alexa at my
fingertips Alexa what's the weather
today right now in Santa Monica it's 72
degrees Fahrenheit with cloudy skies
today's forecast has intermittent clouds
with a high of 72 it doesn't even matter
because I'm inside baking a freaking
pumpkin pie so let's get started thanks
to Amazon fire TV for sponsoring this
video the Amazon fire TV Cube has Alexa
built in so you can control smart home
devices watch all of your favorite
streaming apps movies TV shows and have
the convenience of controlling your TV
hands-free you can launch and control
content from streaming as well as live
cable or satellite channels with just
your voice check out the link in the
description for more info my favorite
thing though is you can have her control
your lights I actually have these lights
set up in my house they are controlled
by hue and that's also connected to my
Alexa app so all I have to say is Alexa
turn off all my lights but since I'm
shooting a video I kind of want those on
so Alexa turn on my lights alright time
to bake a pumpkin pie so first of all I
need to figure out what ingredients I
need so I'm gonna get all of those I'm
gonna lay them out and I'm gonna start
playing the old video up on the
television so that I can see what the
first mistake was 3/4 cup granulated
sugar 1 tisp of salt 1 tisp of ground
cinnamon
one tisp of ground ginger one tisp of
ground cloves we need two eggs and I
just realized I think my ages are
expired I need an emergency extraction
eggs I don't have a pun for that so I'm
just gonna call Jonah
I need help hey convergence see it is an
egg oh my gosh this is Harley you're
brilliant
okay I'm having an egg mergency can you
please bring me two large eggs my gosh
thank you so much they're also eggs I
don't eat this yet I can't believe that
I didn't know it we're supposed to put
crust on top of pumpkin pie you're not a
true pumpkin pie again call me when it's
done
okay Alexa play iJustine pumpkin pie
mistakes on YouTube getting that from
YouTube okay okay we've got all of our
ingredients over here I've got my pan
same pan eggs
[Music]
everything looks the same Alexa play I
have all those things this time it is go
time time mr. belt was now will say
the far field and communication on this
thing is pretty incredible because like
I'm not close but I'm definitely kind of
far away and I'm not even talking that
loud first step we're gonna put all of
the things that the thing makes salt
sugar cinnamon ginger and cloves in a
small bowl beat the eggs in a large bowl
stir in pumpkin and sugar spice mixtures
for graduate butcher
okay I think I've already started making
mistakes by not following the directions
I mean honestly you just put everything
in like you just put it all in you mix
it all together
oh shoot I need it okay I remember I had
this problem last year can opener I
didn't have one so I had two ends on it
what a blow hole you cut it just make a
punch hole and then you blow in the hole
and it all comes out in a perfect
cylinder we're gonna do that oh this is
so fun okay so oh I think I'm doing
something I think I think I broke though
it's supposed to slid okay so wait
Wow Alexa play me a song that you think
I would like this is honestly what I
needed to hear right now
Taylor's worth telling me to calm down
my Savior okay I put all my stuff in
except all the dry ingredients I'm just
gonna put put them all in at the same
time I think I have to preheat 425 for
15 minutes well I'm not ready there yet
because it's clearly taking way too long
[Music]
oh my god
okay I'm gonna bring it the oven now
because because I don't know when the
last one was I clean my oven I don't
think I ever have
I'm gonna clean up my mess I'm gonna set
my mixture aside prepare the crust
poured this in things were happening
guys things were happening I'm gonna
play myself a little cleanup song Alexa
play the cleanup song on YouTube to
clean up song by the computers have you
guys ever heard your songs we I need to
be put away everything's clean Alexa
pause let's go back to my video and make
sure I don't make a mistake here again
one mistake that I definitely know that
I made was the last time I put crust on
top of the pumpkin pie who knew they
were supposed to do that oh that's right
everybody knew except me
Alexa fast forward one minute
alexxa pause so at this point this is
where we'd be playing Alexa play roll
out getting that from you too
Alexa pause okay so we're putting our
pie crust in I'm just kind of like
molding it a little up here just to be
you know like a little more pie like
okay let's pour in this mixture wow the
smell is incredible this smells so good
the consistency looks better yeah I mean
before it was really soupy this looks a
little less soupy let's see here we are
going to be baking this for 40 to 50
minutes or until knife inserted in your
center comes out clean I have to cool it
on a wire rack for two hours I forgot
about that
all right so I guess I'll see you in
like 50 minutes and then two hours after
that it's a big deal I didn't want to
eat this immediately or anything all
right
Alexa set a timer for 45 minutes Alexa
can you add to my shopping list to get
some eggs
I added eggs to your shopping list Alexa
can you order me a new hat on Amazon
one moment based on your order history
I found tattva LED light-up hat beanie
mid-cap Amazon's choices
Louisiana's women belt buckles the bow
that size Carhartt Black Dog app oh and
17 more 17 Alexa ordered that one order
placed your total is $16 in 41 cents
including tax and your gift card was
applied
we'll be delivered by October I chose
the first time I ever did that this is
incredible
amazon knows me so well like i know liz
is a sponsored video but if you guys
know me like i don't even go shopping
anymore like i don't leave the grocery
store like I have Amazon Prime and
delivered to me like I can order things
within 15 minutes Oh like the how much
time is left on my timer you have two
timers a 15 minutes timers with about 12
minutes left and a 45 minutes timer with
about 42 minutes left okay I guess now
we just wait oh oh well oh boy oh my
gosh but 15 minutes timer has finished
my 15 mins 15 mins which means I need to
check my pie okay it is it is definitely
not ready to be had all taken out cuz
it's only been in the oven for 15
minutes so we'll see you when the next
timer happens Oh
timers going off that means it's ready
oh man this looks like a freaking
fantastic delight but now I'm gonna have
to wait two hours because that's what
the directions say and I'm not gonna
mess it up I see you soon hi it is time
for pie so I'm calling you on my echo
it's still a little warm but it's almost
cooled off oh it looks yummy whipped
cream No
I didn't know that whipped cream is
something that you put on since a wait a
minute oh my god she's it what do you
think so far it's really good smells
it's still a little bit warm which is
great because gonna be a couple of this
everything looks perfect I love pumpkin
pie I guess we cut it now oh oh it's
real warm maybe I needed to let it cool
a little longer but I didn't want to
wait anymore
I just feel like warm pumpkin pie
there's nothing better ready I feel
accomplished by USA that louder because
the microphone is here this is way
better than what you've done you can't
you gotta let me hear that oh my gosh oh
my gosh you're right it does need
whipped cream I forgot I can't believe
it well this next year you'll finally
this is so good
I do like the crust as well like I want
to stop eating it so I can let it cool
but then I'm almost done
good job Doug that was the name that I
wanted to name my show good job just I
do things and I do them hopefully right
this is the first episode well guys
thank you so much for watching and I'm
so excited to have a new Amazon edition
of to my kitchen the Amazon fire TV cube
so I can do things like this
Alexa play Janna is Eric videos on
YouTube getting that from you too
oh it is it's awesome good job
Wow well I first map are you guys in the
next video
let me know there's anything else you'd
like to see me make here on YouTube
ladies comment below
oh this is good I'm very fool no no no
no no this is mine
[Music]